Chúng tôi, chúng ngày 30 hôm tâm tâm tâm tâm tâm tâm cơ sở giật mẫu sảo mẩm nâng và tìu học của hà nội.
Phải hoàn thành việc tổn vệ sinh mua chương khử khoảng, nhằm chủ động phòng trong bệnh gái trình miệng và các sĩ mạnh khác.
Sao ngày 30 hôm tâm tâm tâm tâm cơ sở giật sẽ tý tụp duy trì tổn vệ sinh mua chương, khử khoảng phòng trong dịch hàng quân.
Kêu cầu của chính sịch, các nhà chương sẽ tụp trức vệ sinh mua chương khử khoảng nhà ăn sân chơi,
khu hoại cạnh, khu bệ sinh, đồ dùng học tập, đồ chơi trẻ em, đồ dùng cá nhân, ín nhất hai lần trong đột cầu điểm.
Sao đau, các nhà chương dưới chỉ thực hiện hàng quân, nếu suy hiện các bạn hỏng ổn dịch, các trường học sẽ thực hiện thường sẵn của các quán ý tế.
Thưa số liệu của chúng tâm kìm xác hành tà thàn nội, từ ngày 15 hình hành bẩy thức mà,
còn thành phố vi nhận hai chăm 8,5 hình mẹ tăng bố mấy sáo trình hợp xà với tòa trưa đau.
Chúng tòa nguồn vi nhận hai ổn dịch trường học tại sản đại phương và sản chuyên Mỹ,
còn dô năm nay ím không trai lời sau đến đây, còn thành phố vi nhạm của nghiên bà chăm hai ổn dịch, và hai ổn dịch,
trong đó có năm 30 đáng hỏa đồng theo dưới báo số mắc tay trên miệng hành nội,
sẽ tìm tụng gia tăng trong các tòa tử ý.